We are already really guaranteeing them
a welcome so that they can
continue their schooling is an
honor situation that is happening in the
country and making sure that here we are and
can learn social cultural codes
and the language as quickly as
possible  integrating and leading a
healthy life for that went very well
we have the eighty students who
arrived last weekend he
seemed happy to be here the
teacher welcomed him he already had
the opportunity to  'have a few classes and we
see that here and it's a little by little
he looked in good shape this morning we
asked him how he was he said it
's fine it was important to welcome them
so simple welcome so that  for their
well-being which without us being there for them
to support them and can also count
on the support of their comrades
frankly there is a lot of antenna
between the students
and they quickly become friends that's great